hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game i myself have played against
the the paul morphy bought uh on
chess.com while i was uh basically
waiting for my chess master grand master
edition to set up as uh like you guys
requested you wanted me to pair up
the grand master edition of chess master
against the the almighty uh fris plus uh
nnue uh so you know assisted with neural
networks to see the outcome of that
clash because uh we've tested out the
the old uh nintendo entertainment system
chess master against the uh stock fish
and it didn't really go all that well
yeah against stockfish not not fritz uh
i might have said fritz for some reason
uh but yeah against stockfish and while
i was waiting i i decided to test out uh
one of the bots and i i thought there
was a paul morphe bot so
i thought it would be a really really
cool idea and uh the bot is rated some
2500 but it's not 2500
like you would have it a standard bot uh
it's fixed that it uh you know plays a
bit more aggressive it sacrifices a bit
more and it tries to get an active play
so i gave morphe the white pieces um
i i thought it would make for for a more
interesting game
to see how it would attack uh and i made
all of my moves pretty much instantly as
uh for those of you who have been
following the paul morphy saga uh you
know that it's been um well sort of an
issue for morphe when his opponents took
way way too long to to actually make a
move and i thought okay it's a i mean
it's a very strong engine i'm going to
lose either way so i might as well uh
you know
just play what comes to mind and the
game actually turned out pretty okay uh
until something uh completely wild
happened so uh let's uh let's dive
straight into it so the paul morphe bot
uh has the white pieces uh and uh for
some reason my board is tilted a little
bit so sorry about that i will fix that
in a second sometimes this happens i
have no idea why
uh
and then i never realized it and then it
stays like that for the entire recording
but now i've i've actually caught it so
uh
nicely done by me uh so yeah and also uh
let me just flip the board this is uh
looking very weird uh okay so morphe has
the white pieces uh and uh he opens with
pawn to d4 and this was already uh quite
a quite uh a surprise for me as well who
would expect morphy to play d4 and
that's something that i think chess.com
has to fix i mean everyone expects
morphy to just play e4 and that's it uh
but there's also an uh agar matrobot on
ancient.com you can play against sort of
my bot
uh but people have been sending me that
when whenever they played the evan's
gambit i saw i declined the evidence
gambit and that's i mean that's
sacrilege um so i i hope they fixed that
or maybe they have fixed it i don't know
but okay getting back to the game morphe
played d4 and i played knight to f6 as i
usually do uh we have c4 and now e6 by
me we have knight to c3 and okay i
played the nimso indian bishop to b4 uh
we have knight to f3 this is the three
night variations uh variation of the
nimzo and usually whenever we have this
position i always say that basically
nowadays everyone plays queen to c2 or
e3
but knight to f3 is a move you don't see
very often and the top replies here are
c5 and b6 however i have no idea what to
play here uh so i just transpose into
the aragos in defense as i i did some
some work undergoes and so i thought
maybe this was my best option morphe
went bishop to d2 which was also very
weird for me and i played d captures on
c4 giving morphe the full center i want
to experience the full wrath of the old
master and of course here we have pawn
to e4 uh ponte e3 is a normal move that
white should make here you just defend
your d4 pawn you prepare to open uh the
capture on c4 but morphy sacrificed upon
here with e4 which already brings us to
a very very interesting game and it's
not a good move but i have to play a
very very forcing line i have to play
bishop captures on c3 and after bishop
captures capture the pawn he will
capture on c4 i will capture here b
captures on c3 and this will give me a
very very good position i'm gonna play
knight d7 bring the knight to f6 play b6
put the bishop on this diagonal and
there's really nothing um
there's not much to worry about let's
say castles castles rook to e1 b6 the
bishop will be developed and black has a
fine position and no standard worries
like you have in the names of indian or
the ragosan defense where white can
harass you along the c file or or maybe
with some queen a4 ideas attacking a7
blocking the c6 square so those are some
of the ideas that are non-existent here
so this would would have been best but i
never even considered capturing an e4 as
i i i mean i'm playing against an engine
i thought of course uh uh the the ball
cannot be captured so i just castled
here yeah and now morphy played e5 i
played knight to d5 and here we have
bishop characters on c4 and okay i
played b6 i'm saying now okay i'm not
gonna play bishop to b7 or maybe even
bishop to a6 if uh you know the position
calls for it uh sorry about that morphy
played castles and now i just traded
knight captures and c3 expecting a
recapture but here is the move that
really came as a surprise morphe played
queen to c2 and it's not a great move
but it's a very very tricky one and i
was very very much weirded out by this
and i instantly played knights to e to
check which to my surprise is the
absolute best move i mean we have to
give the back of the piece somehow
problem is if you go back knight to d5
to kind of save the piece then bishop
captures on d5 comes with an attack on
the rook that's the problem and after i
recapture bishop captures on b4 attacks
my rook here and now uh okay the game
can still be played i have to play rook
to e8 which is weird and if you play the
move you want to play rook to d8 to put
more pressure on the on white center
then the game is just dead lost knight
g5 goes threatens this and after uh
uh g6 now the rook here becomes a target
and now after you move the rook knight
e4 and that's it there's no defense
against knight to f6 uh the queen rook
and king are perfectly placed for the
knight and whatever you play here it's
lost
uh so to my amazement when i was
analyzing the game afterwards knight the
e2 is indeed the absolute best move to
play so okay bishop characters on e2 i
played bishop characters on d2 knight
captures on d2 and now i played bishop
to b7 putting my bishop on this long
diagonal and okay i still have to work
on my development but um i mean it's not
like white is really threatening
anything so bishop to f3 by morphy and i
captured bishop captures knight captures
and i played knight to d7 shifting my
knight over uh
not to f6 uh but preparing c5 as the
knight is now nicely guarding this um
the rook is coming to c8 rook 8 to c1
putting pressure on c7 and i play rook
to c8 now hoping to get that c5 move in
and if i can get that in then my
position is perfectly fine so rook after
d1 now making it a bit tricky as the
rook is now aligned with my queen so i
play queen to e7 and here we have queen
to a4 now the a7 pawn is undefended and
morphe of course is attacking it and
here i should play a5 or even c5 in some
lines can be can be pretty good
and c5 is indeed the move i played my
idea was that if morphe captures on a7
i'm going to play rook here and indeed
this would not be all that great for
white queen to b7 rook and go here queen
to c6 i'm going to capture the pawn on
a2 and now let's say d captures on c5
knight captures and c5 and we get this
position where uh you know okay white is
always a little bit better he has uh
you know
some pressure against my
uh but uh you know i i feel that uh you
know
if i don't really mess something up you
you will be able to play this so instead
uh more
instead of going for this morphe plate
pawn to d5 again uh continuing in in
great style as uh one would expect of
the great paul morphy he captures on the
e5 i played rook captures on the e5 and
now as my a7 pawn is kind of hanging i
played knight to b8 and again to my
amazement it is the strongest move
recommended by the engine i am defending
this pawn with my queen
rook c to d1 morphe now gains full
control over the d file and i play rook
f to d8 i want to trade everything along
the d file and then
enjoy enjoy a nice end game and here we
have rook to d6 uh it seems like you
could just trade here for example rook
captures rook captures rook captures
queen captures and grab the pawn however
his back rank is queenie one would be
checkmate so that's out of the question
so here morphe played rook to d6 and my
position is still fine i can either
trade here or i could you know just wait
and see what happens play some like h6
but basically best is to trade and then
offer a queen trade and then fight
against this past
d6 pawn which again is very far advanced
and strong uh but with with uh some
a few good moves you should be able to
counter white's position however here
after rook to d6 i played uh well
up until this point i played a
reasonably good game not not a great one
if it was a real engine and not a morphe
engine he would have crushed me a long
time ago
but here i played knight to c6 and i i
felt very good about my position i added
another defender to the a7 pawn added
another defender to the rook added
another attacker to the e5 pawn so what
could go wrong here well
feel free to pause the video and uh
we'll show show everyone what could go
wrong here while i give you a couple of
seconds and to win the game for morphe
have at it
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on punishing this uh
you know uh just i mean it's just a
terrible terrible insolence of a move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course queen
captures on c6 this is what morphe
played and now i have realized uh what
i've done my back rank is just terrible
and uh well i i can just resign the game
here uh or i could maybe drag it out
play a piece down but uh you know as
murphy lived his life as a gentleman i
decided to end this game as a gentleman
and allow the checkmates to happen on
the board so i accepted the queen here
morphy played rook capture 78 i
recaptured and the rook captures and the
eighth morphe delivers a back rank
checkmate
so very nicely played by morphe
like i said uh i i played a a a couple
of sub-optimal moves and if it was a
real engine of course it would have
crushed me way way uh quicker uh but
here uh morphe is designed or rather
murphy's bot is designed to play
interesting moves to try and play
attacking chess to try and sacrifice and
that's why he gave me a few chances and
i got a decent position in the end like
i said
if this knight the c6 move doesn't
appear on the board the position is very
much playable but i play knight c6 and
well the the rest is history
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very nicely played by by
morphe i i never actually saw lines like
these because no one plays them but as
you can see for for a blitz game and for
some quick formal games or you know even
faster for bullet you should know them
as someone might use them against you
so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i'm still preparing the uh
uh the stockfish versus chessmaster
grand master edition brawl so stay tuned
for that i would like to thank robert
aratune ravishing reptiles youtube
rosman rickard uh gerhart
and nagarjuna ponogoti for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day